our real estate operates out of our
corporate office in Nashville but um
yeah we we have our own Investments that
that we do but we yeah we don't do
services for other people you're not
like Brokers no no I'm still licensed as
a real estate agent up in in BC but uh I
don't we closed our Brokers it was
interesting because when we we were
running our brokerage we had other
agents working for us and then we
started Property Brothers took off
immediately within three months we were
the number one show in the network and
that was that's an amazing story that
was in Toronto right yeah so it was
actually originally the show aired in
Canada it was turned down by the US
Network there wasn't it originally you
got uh they wanted you to do a show with
a girl no no originally Drew got hired
to do a show called realtor Idol it was
like American Idol for realtors and and
he calls me he's like dude I green l a
show and he's like tells me what it is
realtor Idol I'm like that's the dumbest
I've ever heard no one's going to
watch that show fortunately that didn't
go anywhere I pitched that production
company Jonathan me what we were doing
with clients at the time but the funny
thing is in the very beginning because
we both got in there and real Idol what
was it did just I want to hear what that
concept it honestly it was just a bunch
of Realtors competing to get clients
kind of a thing and and sell houses and
but was there a panel it they didn't get
that far I mean I auditioned and it
didn't go anywhere but it was just a
dumb idea but um they wanted when we
first green lit for Property Brothers
they wanted me to be the bronny
construction guy because they thought he
looked more like a suit guy with his
fancy longer hair do you remember
Jonathan's old hair a lion ass M
beautiful blond he like he was inspired
by Zig freed oroy I existed in slow
motion
wind but he then then they realized uh
he's a licensed contractor I was a
licensed realtor not a contractor and so
like oh this could go wrong if we had
the non-c contractor guy pretending to
be a contractor so they went to what was
real but we I remember early in the
early days we tried to to film the show
so we were away on location filming my
brokerage was in Alberta and uh it was
there was too much liability cuz I as so
I was actually the broker of our real
estate company and so I had to review
every single contract for every single
property still trying to film and then
there would be like a closing happening
I'm filming cut I quickly have to make a
call to the lawyer and blah and so we
finally just decided to hang up the Hat
of The Brokerage and just do the shows
and so on our shows we we no longer have
we don't buy and sell houses with
clients the only house show we buy on is
brother versus brother where Jonathan I
each buy a house renovate it we compete
we flip and whoever makes more money
wins money goes to charity all the
others are homeowners whether you've had
your house for 5 days or 50 years you're
eligible um for the show
yeah